[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today what's
going on Joe hey I was calling in I was
wondering um how do I go about dating
when I come from an affluent family um
you know many girls parents will see me
as a big dollar sign instead of seeing
me for who I am and I was wondering I
was wondering what your thoughts are
because I faced that problem with many
families is how do they know that's what
I was going to say
um you know usually when you meet a
girl's parents they ask you what your
parents do for work which is a very um
normal thing to ask somebody and then
when you tell them can you come from
yeah can we ask you what what do your
parents do for
work um well it's more of my family um I
I have multiple cardiologists in my
family between my cousins and everyone
okay so
uh and that's your leading talking point
when you're on a date I don't understand
how your whole family comes up in the
situation well um not when you're on a
date but when the girl brings you around
her parents and what's your okay so
what's your family's net worth like just
your immediate family what's the net
worth of your
parents um it's
substantial 10 million 20 million
uh yes okay so I would not have garnered
that just from you talking to me I would
have thought oh they're doctors that's
great um if if if I said to you Joe what
do your parents do and you said oh
they're in the medical field and I said
really U well what do they do in the
medical field if you said oh my dad's a
heart surgeon and my mom's a
anesthesiologist real talk I would be
like okay they got some coin like I
would just derive that but I don't think
that I would even think to ask further
there I wouldn't go really so how has
that calcul so how are they getting to
the point of knowing does your family
have a name that people
recognize in the community that's
correct yes in Jacksonville Florida okay
so is there a name on a hospital or
something like
that yes yes it is I see okay so it's
much more obvious than you having to
bring it up and talk about it exactly
that's what does the the family have to
do with it what is your fear going into
this they see you as a dollar sign what
does that mean to you
well I it just really uh worries me
because I have to wonder what they're
telling what you know the girls parents
are going to tell their daughter when
I'm not around um you know what um like
don't let him go make sure you do you
know don't I get it I get it taking
taking more interest in me than other
other people
yeah H well I think you're going to need
some discernment as you date to just go
is her heart in it would she have
married me if if my family was brok is
that really a big factor how are you
finding these dates
currently um well you know just around
town in church things like that you know
I try to stay off the internet but you
know that's kind of this day and age
yeah so the people in your church um
they must know your family yes yes
that's correct so there's part of this
that there's part of this that could be
very real and there's part of this that
could be perceived right
because uh if I go back if I go to my
home church people know oh Jade she
works for ramsy she's on the Ramsey Show
like she has this cool job but it
doesn't really change I could talk
myself into thinking they're going to
see me different and they're going to
talk to me different but it doesn't
really change anything cuz they've been
knowing me for how you know 10 years
however long I've been at the church so
is there a piece of this that you're
just worried about it or have you seen
it play out and actually be a
reality um
there was
um an instance where I was talking to a
girl at a wedding that I had met and the
father wanted to get his daughter and
leave the wedding everybody was leaving
uhhuh and he asked uh the groom what my
name was and he told the father my name
and the father said okay well we'll just
wait around and give them a minute to
talk to each other weird I mean that's
weird but that's also like I feel like
there is you should expect for there to
be some like jerk moves or you know dumb
people are going to have dumb moments
for sure but I definitely don't want
that to talk you out of dating a really
nice girl and because here's the thing
you're whether wealthy or not you're
going to go down the
line with plenty of girls thinking I I
like I liked her and then it's not going
to work out regardless of having wealth
you might get to the point of thinking
this is the one and then it doesn't work
out I think that that's happened to
everybody right and so I think that
you're going to know pretty early in
whether someone has ulterior motives or
not and maybe that's you developing kind
of your own spidey sense spidey sense or
a little scre a little sneaky screening
test that you do when you're talking to
people and or there's a little checklist
of red flags that you look for when
they're talking to you are they talking
about money in a way that you think is a
red flag are they talking about are they
asking you more questions um about your
family than they're asking about you
right I think it's you going okay what
what is it that I need to be looking for
um when I'm going on dates also who is
it like if if somebody is setting me up
who do I trust to say oh I have a friend
you know they'll be you know because I
do think that um I think that the circle
of people that you get in is really
important
because people know each other right and
it's like at my church the folks that I
roll with at my church they know people
and I know that the people they know are
good people and then I since those
people are good people it's like it's
almost like birds of a feather flocking
together true and so I would probably
just decide like hey I I don't
really there's certain people that if
they say hey I have somebody I'm going
to set you up on a date with I'm like
okay no thank you you know yeah I also
wonder if he got out of his own Circle
uh Joe would that help because they
don't know you from Adam at that point
that's also good you know to where
they're they're seeking you out for the
right reasons and My worry is that it's
going to be more paranoia in your head
of like oh gosh they're trying to get up
the family's money and they don't really
care about me and that's what I don't
want you to have I would just walk into
it and just be Joe and take things slow
ask the right questions you know
establish boundaries be transparent
that's the best thing you can do in
these situations and over time you'll
Vibe it out and you go no that's a good
family those are good parents they're
not out my money and that that's always
going to be a factor though you know
yeah Rachel Ramsey when she was in
college and met Winston Winston was like
Dave who's that guy yeah and so that was
a big factor of there was no weirdness
there yeah I think honestly I think a
lot of it could be in his head right now
he had that one moment that like kind of
freaked him out and that can definitely
give you make you
gunshy31 that's great I'm not thinking
St Jude it must be them this is the
Ramsey Show create your free every dooll
budget today the simplest way to budget
for your life